how they say I hate women and I'm  misogynistic and they'll give me a  couple examples they'll say they'll say  it's because  I tell fat people they're fat  I'll tell men they're fat too  Brett like I'm not gonna go out of my  way if I just see if that person walking  down the street but like why do I have  to see your roles look I don't even  consider myself thin enough to be  wearing one of those bikini things at  the beach why you guys put me through  that I feel the same way about girls  that have their cheeks out why do I have  to look at your cheeks  why I don't like women I know the men  are like oh no don't tell them to put  them away but me I'm like I don't want  to see your ass  I just came here to chill